ANDREW HUBERMAN: Welcome
to the Huberman Lab podcast
where we discuss science
and science-based tools
for everyday life.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
I'm Andrew Huberman,
and I'm a professor
of neurobiology
and ophthalmology
at Stanford School of Medicine.
Today is an Ask Me
Anything episode, or AMA.
This is part of our
premium subscriber channel.
Our premium subscriber
channel was started in order
to provide support for
the standard Huberman Lab
podcast, which comes
out every Monday
and is available at
zero cost to everybody
on all standard feeds--
YouTube, Apple,
Spotify and elsewhere.
We also started the
premium channel as a way
to generate support for exciting
research being done at Stanford
and elsewhere, research
on human beings that
leads to important
discoveries that
assist mental health, physical
health, and performance.
I'm also pleased to inform
you that for every dollar
the Huberman Lab premium channel
generates for research studies,
the Tiny Foundation has
agreed to match that amount.
So now we are able to double
the total amount of funding
given to studies of mental
health, physical health
and human performance.
If you'd like to subscribe
to the Huberman Lab podcast
premium channel, please go
to hubermanlab.com/premium.
It is $10 a month to subscribe,
or you can pay $100 all at once
to get an entire 12-month
subscription for a year.
We also have a lifetime
subscription model
that is a one-time payment.
And again, you can
find that option
at hubermanlab.com/premium.
For those of you that
are already subscribers
to the premium channel, please
go to hubermanlab.com/premium
and download the premium
subscription feed.
And for those of you that
are not Huberman Lab podcast
premium subscribers,
you can still
hear the first 20 minutes
of today's episode
and determine whether or not
becoming a premium subscriber
is for you.
So without further
ado, let's get
to answering your questions.
The first question
is about resveratrol.
The question
specifically is, and I
quote, "there seems to be a lot
of conjecture about resveratrol
and whether or not it
can extend lifespan.
Could you please tell us your
thoughts on this subject?"
OK, well, I will indeed tell
you my thoughts on this subject.
And I'll use it
as an opportunity
to also give you my thoughts
about supplementation
for sake of longevity, that
is, for extending lifespan,
more generally.
So resveratrol got
a lot of attention
some years back
because, at the time,
it was believed that
supplementing with resveratrol
could impact certain cellular
pathways that would extend not
just the lifespan of
those individual cells
but perhaps the lifespan of the
entire organism, meaning us,
humans.
And as a consequence,
supplements
such as resveratrol supplements
but also grape seed extracts,
which we know contain a
fair amount of resveratrol
or can be converted
into resveratrol, also
received a lot of attention
for their potential
to increase lifespan.
I think by now, 2023,
it's fair to say
that most of that thinking has
been, let's just say, debunked.
I think that most
people understand
that while indeed
resveratrol might
have some positive effects on
the functioning of our cells
that there is very
little, if any,
direct evidence that resveratrol
can increase lifespan.
If you are aware of any data
to the contrary that is modern,
is highly controlled,
and even better,
was carried out in human
studies or non-human primate
studies or even
mouse studies, please
put links to those in
the comments on YouTube,
because I'd love to see
those studies, especially
recent studies.
But my current
line of thinking is
that resveratrol while it may
have certain health benefits
does not seem to
increase lifespan.
Now, with that
said, that doesn't
mean that things like
resveratrol or grape seed
extract are of zero utility.
In fact, I take 400 to 800
milligrams of grape seed
extract, usually with a meal.
It's just part of my
standard supplementation
stack every single day.
But I do that mainly for its
effects on vascular function
and blood flow and
a few other effects
that grape seed extract
has been related to.
The data there, I would say,
are reasonably strong, strong
enough certainly
that when weighed
against the potential downsides
of taking grape seed extract,
including the cost of
grape seed extract,
lead me to take 400
to 800 milligrams
grape seed extract per day.
I just do that as a kind
of general insurance policy
against a number of things.
And it's part of a
small kit of supplements
that I take that fall
into that category,
meaning supplements that appear
to be very safe, certainly
at the dosages that
I just referred to,
supplements that
potentially are having
positive effects on
our cells, and that are
fairly if not very low cost.
So that's why I take
grape seed extract.
I do not take it for
its potential impact
on resveratrol and
resveratrol-related pathways
per se and certainly not
to extend my lifespan.
So that basically answers the
question that I was asked,
which is what are your
thoughts on resveratrol
for extending lifespan.
My answer was I don't
think it extends lifespan.
But I take something related
to resveratrol for other health
purposes.
And by the way, I
certainly wouldn't
place grape seed extract
in my list of top five
or even top 10 supplements
if somebody, for instance,
said I want to take anywhere
from one to 10 supplements,
and I have x amount of budget
to devote to supplementation.
And I'm thinking about
taking grape seed extract.
Would that be one of
the top 10 supplements
you would recommend?
I certainly wouldn't
put it in the top 10.
And by the way, at some point
in the not too distant future,
I will put online--
so I'll probably do a
podcast episode-- listing
out all the supplements that
I take and the rationale
behind those and how long I've
taken them and the effects
that I've observed both
subjectively and in my blood
work and what I recommend to
other people, what I don't
recommend to other people,
what's specific to me,
and so on and so forth.
But meanwhile, that's my
answer to the question.
I don't think resveratrol
increases longevity.
At least, I'm not aware
of any direct evidence
for that in humans.
Now, with that said, let's
use this as an opportunity
to talk about some of the
other so-called longevity
supplements and drugs that
are often discussed online
and elsewhere in terms of their
efficacy to increase lifespan.
About four or five
years ago, there
was a sudden and
increased attention
on NAD-related pathways
for increasing longevity.
So the NAD pathway, as some
of you may already know,
is a pathway within
all of our cells.
This is a pathway that is
highly active in young animals
and humans.
But all animals and humans
across the entire lifespan
make NAD in their cells.
It's related to
cellular energetics.
That is the production
of energy in cells.
It has direct relevance
to mitochondrial
function and mitochondrial
function to it.
And that's a
discussion unto itself.
But suffice it to say that
the pathway leading to NAD
includes things
such as NR and NMN.
NR and NMN are considered by
many to be precursors to NAD.
OK, so why am I telling
you all these acronyms?
Here's the deal.
The argument was made, in
fact, by some prior guests
on the Huberman Lab podcast and
elsewhere that by increasing
NAD levels in our cells
that one could potentially
extend lifespan.
And there are generally
three ways in which people
have attempted to do that.
OK, we'll talk about whether or
not increasing NAD in our cells
actually increases
lifespan in a moment.
But for the time being,
let's just talk about some
of the ways that people
have tried to increase NAD
within their brain and body.
The most typical ways
that people have done that
is through, until very
recently, supplementation.
And so there are supplements
out there such as NR which we
know can increase NAD levels.
So this is taken as
a pill or a powder,
typically as a
capsule or a powder.
Or by taking NMN which,
and here there's been some,
let's just say,
debate as to whether
or not taking NMN actually
leads to increases
in NAD within our
cells, whether or not
it can get into our
it's converted into NAD,
and so on and so on.
But there again, the idea
was by taking NAD either
in capsule form, or
it's sometimes taken
as a sublingual powder, that
one could increase NAD levels
and thereby potentially
increase lifespan.
And then there's a third
way that's commonly
used to try and
increase NAD levels,
and that's by infusing
by intravenous infusion,
or in some cases, by oral
administration, either liquid
or pill form, NAD itself.
Now, I confess that I have tried
all three of these approaches.
OK, so I do indeed take an
NR supplement every day.
I take 500 milligrams of NR.
I also and have separately
taken an NMN supplement.
I take sublingual NMN.
So I'll take anywhere
from 1 to 2 grams of NMN
as a sublingual powder,
which as the name suggests,
you put it under your tongue,
and it dissolves there.
It's got this kind
of tangy flavor.
And the goal for me in taking
an NR and NMN each day--
and I should mention that
sometimes I have just
taken NMN or just NR to do the
comparison between NR and NMN
for me in a subjective way, just
comparing what are my energy
levels, how do I
feel, whether or not
there are any side effects.
And then I've also
taken them together.
And I've arrived at a
protocol where I take
NR and NMN every single day.
And the goal of that is
indeed to increase NAD levels
within my system.
However, and I really
want to emphasize this,
I do not take NR and NMN in
order to increase my lifespan.
In fact, at this
point in history,
it's unclear and seems somewhat
unlikely that increasing NAD is
going to increase lifespan.
But I think we should
always keep our minds open.
There may be data to
arrive in the future that
shows that actually
does happen in humans.
Now, there are some animal data
suggesting that increasing NAD
either by taking NR and/or
NMN can increase lifespan.
But frankly, that is not
why I take NR and NMN.
I take NR and NMN in an
effort to increase NAD.
And now I realize what I'm about
to say is entirely subjective.
And I really want
to highlight that.
What I'm about to
describe is my experience.
It is not based on any
peer-reviewed studies.
When I take NR and
NMN at the dosages
I talked about a
little bit earlier,
it gives me a lot of sustained
mental and physical energy
throughout the day.
Now, I've always had a lot of
mental and physical energy.
But I'm 48 years old now.
And I'm interested
in doing anything
that I safely can to keep
those levels of energy
as high as is reasonable, right?
I don't want to
have so much energy
that I can't sit still
or so much energy
that I can't sleep at night.
But I find that when I take
NR and NMN in the morning--
so typically, I'll do
this before my first meal.
I don't really regulate how
close it is to that first meal.
So I'll wake up,
use the bathroom,
hydrate, get my sunlight,
do all the things I've
talked about on other podcasts.
But I'll take my
NR and NMN sometime
usually within
about an hour or two
of waking up and typically
at least 30 minutes
to two hours before my first
meal, which for me usually
arrives around 11:00 a.m.
So sometimes I'll take it
long before my first meal.
In any event, it gives
me a lot of energy.
And I seem to have that
energy throughout the day.
I have gone periods
of time where
I stopped taking NR and/or NMN.
And while I didn't feel
as if I was completely
depleted of energy, I did
notice a decrement in energy
compared to when
I took NR and NMN.
Now, I want to be
very, very clear.
I have no, zero,
financial relationship
to any company that
manufactures NR.
And while I used to have a
relationship to a company that
made NMN, as of
recently, there's
an FDA ruling that has made NMN
not available as a supplement
in the wider world.
So earlier this year--
that is in 2023--
there was a filing for
NMN as a experimental drug
in a clinical trial.
And as a consequence, NMN
was listed as a banned or not
allowed to be commercially
sold supplement.
And that has to do with
some of the legality
around clinical trials.
And when something is listed
as an experimental drug,
it can't be listed
as a supplement.
Nonetheless, you can still
find NMN on the open market.
You can find it on Amazon.
I can't really
speak to the purity
of one source versus another.
You'll have to explore
that on your own.
But I will say this, even
though I said it before.
I have zero financial
relationship
to any company that manufactures
and sells NMN at this time
or NR at this time.
So the short summary to
this whole discussion
about NR and NMN is
that I take NR and NMN,
but I take it because I
like how it makes me feel.
It increases my energy
levels in the morning
and throughout the day.
And it does so in
a way that tapers
off nicely in the
evening, and I can still
fall asleep, et cetera.
I do not take it
with any expectation
that it's going to
increase my lifespan,
simply because I don't think
the data substantiating
the extension and
lifespan are here yet.
They may arrive at some point.
But I don't think that
they are here yet.
So there are a good
number of people out there
that still take NR and/or NMN
and are doing so in efforts
to increase NAD.
And so let's take a moment
and talk about increasing NAD
directly, because
that's something
that I have some recent
experience with, and that's
becoming more common and
is, yes, still FDA approved,
at least as far as I know.
There are companies that
can come to your house,
or you can go to a
facility, and they
will give you an NAD infusion.
So they will infuse you
directly with NAD into the vein.
I've done this twice now.
And I will say, as
most people experience
when they do an NAD infusion,
it's pretty darn uncomfortable.
In fact, so much so
that a lot of people
have to take anti-nausea meds in
order to get the NAD infusion.
I opted to not take
the anti-nausea meds,
not because I'm
particularly tough,
but because I don't like taking
additional medication if I can.
But I've taken anywhere from
500 to 1,000 milligrams of NAD
by infusion.
I did that at times when
I was feeling particularly
rundown or post-illness.
And I did indeed find that after
the NAD infusion was complete,
I felt much, much better in
a number of different ways--
improved sleep, improved vigor,
coming off those illnesses.
I felt much better.
But again, there is
no clinical trial
exploring NAD infusion
for sake of vigor,
et cetera, that I am aware of.
I just happen to
be somebody who is
interested in exploring these
tools and techniques from time
to time.
And I deemed this as safe.
Whether or not
it's safe for you,
you have to explore
with your physician.
Also, I do want to reemphasize
what I said a moment ago.
Those NAD infusions are
pretty darn uncomfortable.
You can have the
person administering
the infusion adjust the
rate of the infusion
so that the drip
is slower, which
makes it more tolerable
as opposed to trying
to get the whole infusion bag
in there in 45 minutes or less.
I just wanted to get the
whole thing over with.
So I just said, put it in
as quickly as you reasonably
and safely can.
It took about an hour,
maybe 45 minutes to an hour.
Initially, I felt nauseous.
I felt like someone was
stepping on my chest.
stepping on my legs.
I felt like, well,
I just felt lousy.
I felt so awful.
And then after about
10 minutes, it passed.
And I felt fine.
And then after the infusion was
done, as I mentioned before,
I felt terrific.
I was still able to fall
asleep that night just fine,
although I did make it a point
to do this earlier in the day.
I have heard of some people
doing NAD infusions later
in the day and having
challenges with sleep.
But again, that's
just anecdotal.
Or we could call it anecdata,
if you want, but it's anecdotal.
It's generally assumed
for obvious reasons
that NAD infusions are more
effective at increasing
cellular levels of NAD
than NR or NMN or both
together, although the direct
comparison has not been made,
as far as I know.
And there's still this
general question as to
whether or not any of this stuff
is getting into cells directly
and impacting NAD levels
in specific cells,
although I think most
people assume that the NAD
infusions certainly are.
Now, there are a number of
different experts out there
who debate all the fine points
of everything that I just said,
people like Dr. Charles
Brenner and people
like Dr. David Sinclair,
people like Matt Kaeberlein.
There are people
who really actively,
and let's just say, heatedly
debate all the issues
that I just talked about.
I think the greatest debate
is around whether or not
increasing NAD levels in cells
actually increases lifespan.
But there's also a debate
around whether or not
NR is more advantageous than
NMN, whether or not all of this
is too premature to
explore yet already.
Again, I just want to
restate for the third time.
I don't do any of this
stuff in these NAD pathways
for sake of increasing lifespan.
I do it for sake of the
vitality and energy effects
that I subjectively experience.
I must say that the NAD
infusions are expensive enough,
inconvenient enough, and let's
just say uncomfortable enough
that I don't see myself
doing them very often,
although perhaps maybe doing
them a couple of times a year
or more makes sense
should I find myself
feeling run down or post-illness
fatigue or things of that sort.
I would be very curious
to learn from any of you,
the audience, what
sorts of things
you've experienced
if perhaps you've
explored NR supplementation,
NMN supplementation, or NAD
infusions.
And as I mentioned
earlier, there's
now a growing number
of different products
that claim that you
can take NAD orally,
so either in pill,
tincture or other forms,
so no requirement
for an infusion.
But I'm not aware of any
studies that have directly
linked oral NAD to
NAD levels in cells
and how those two things relate.
So lots more important science
to be done in this area, lots
more debate surely to
be had, and any time we
talk about supplements,
I just want
to emphasize several times that
I do see supplements as indeed
supplements.
I think only by getting your
light exposure, sunshine,
movement, nutrition,
stress modulation,
social relationships, et
cetera, correct should you even
begin to consider
supplementation,
because supplementation
is just not
at the foundation of mental
health, physical health,
and performance.
It is indeed something
that, provided
it fits within your safety
and economic frameworks,
could potentially
enhance mental health,
physical health,
performance in certain ways.
But it's certainly
not the foundation
from which you build mental
health, physical health,
and performance.
So now we've talked about
resveratrol, a little bit
about grape seed extract.
We've talked about NR and NMN
and NAD and the NAD pathway.
There are a few other
things that are commonly
discussed in the longevity
sphere, let's call
it, things such as metformin.
I'll just be very direct and
say I do not take metformin.
And I also don't
take what some people
call the poor man's version of
metformin, which is berberine.
Berberine gives me
brutal headaches.
Berberine lowers blood glucose.
That's why I think it's
giving me brutal headaches.
A lot of people
have explored or are
thinking about exploring taking
metformin or berberine for sake
of lowering blood glucose and
lowering a particular cellular,
let's just say, pathway or
a set of molecules, mTOR
being the most common of them.
mTOR, mammalian
Target of Rapamycin,
is abundant in developing cells.
It's responsible for the
growth of individual cells.
And the amount of
mTOR in our cells
tapers off across our lifespan.
mTOR and its
pathways is something
that I've actually worked
on fairly extensively
in my laboratory in the
context of the regeneration
of the visual system.
So I'm very familiar with it.
And for sake of convenience
and ease in this conversation,
we can just think
of mTOR as something
that's abundant in
cells during development
and any time cells
are growing, including
the growth of tumor
cells, and cellular growth
at any stage of the lifespan.
So the logic that
people have waged
is that drugs like metformin
or compounds like berberine
that reduce mTOR levels or
impact the mTOR pathway in ways
that lead to net
decreases in mTOR,
the logic is that could
somehow increase lifespan.
There's also the logic that
fasting can reduce mTOR
which can increase lifespan.
I don't think there's any
direct evidence for that
yet, however, at
least not in humans.
So I'll tell you.
I don't take berberine for the
reasons I mentioned before.
It makes me feel uncomfortable.
Not psychologically
uncomfortable,
it makes me feel
physically uncomfortable.
I don't take metformin because
expert colleagues of mine,
including Dr. Peter Attia,
have come on this podcast.
In fact, we did a collaboration
journal club podcast
that we'll provide a
link to in the show
note captions during which
we, meaning mainly Peter,
reviewed the peer-reviewed
data on metformin and lifespan.
And at least to
my understanding,
at present, there
isn't sufficient data
to support taking metformin
for increasing lifespan.
So that's why I don't take it.
I may in the future if more
data come out and things change.
But right now, I see no
reason to take metformin
to increase my lifespan.
So I don't take metformin.
Similarly, there's
a lot of discussion
out there about rapamycin.
Remember mTOR, mammalian
Target of Rapamycin,
is so named because it's a
target of this drug, which
is used largely as
an anticancer drug
but has other purposes as well.
Rapamycin is actively
under investigation,
which makes it sound like
there was a crime committed.
But as far as I
know, there wasn't.
Under active
scientific exploration
would be the more
accurate way to say it,
by excellent researchers such
as Dr. Matt Kaeberlein up
at the University of
Washington in Seattle.
He's been looking at
rapamycin for its ability
to extend lifespan, focusing
on many different species,
including dogs.
So he has a dog
longevity project.
So that's really interesting.
Dr. Peter Attia has talked
a lot about rapamycin
and did a recent
podcast about rapamycin
with not only Matt
Kaeberlein but one
of the experts in
the world on mTOR.
So I invite you to check
out that podcast if you
want to learn about rapamycin.
So there is a fair
amount of understanding
about the biological pathways
of rapamycin and mTOR and so on.
And there are
clinician physicians,
like Peter as well
as others, who
are quite excited about
the potential for rapamycin
to extend lifespan, although
you have to go directly
to Peter to find out
exactly what he's doing,
whether or not he's
taking rapamycin or not.
I certainly can't speak for him.
But at present, I
don't take rapamycin.
Why don't I take rapamycin?
Well, I don't take rapamycin
because at least to my eye,
the data at present
don't justify
that for sake of
increasing lifespan.
That is not to
say that rapamycin
isn't an effective drug for the
treatment of various cancers
and for other purposes.
But for me, at
this point in time,
I just don't see a
good reason for me
to take rapamycin relative to
some of the, let's just say,
substantiated potential
side effects of rapamycin.
It is a drug that I
think can be taken safely
under certain conditions but has
enough of a side effect profile
that I'm not
interested in taking it
for sake of increasing
lifespan at this time.
So no metformin, no
rapamycin for me right now,
perhaps in the future.
I've listed out
the things that I'm
perfectly willing and happy
to do, grape seed extract, NR
and NMN, the
occasional NAD infusion
to increase NAD directly,
and for the time being,
I've decided to stay away
from metformin and rapamycin.
But of course, any
and all of that
could change going
forward depending
on the data that are published
and my own experiences.
As a final point on this,
I want to again emphasize
that the foundation of a
quality life and a long life
is most certainly going to
come from the basics, perhaps
the most fundamental
and important of which
is to get sufficient amounts
of quality sleep each night.
We know that not
doing that can indeed
reduce your lifespan if not
directly, then certainly
indirectly by increased
number of accidents
and certainly being far
less happy and energetic
during the day.
So that's fundamental.
Also, and this is very
important to emphasize--
and here I'm essentially
borrowing the words straight
out of Dr. Peter Attia's mouth.
So forgive me, Peter.
This won't be nearly
as eloquent or succinct
as Peter would make it.
But it is very, very clear
that at present there
is no supplement or drug
for increasing longevity
that even comes close to the
known improvements in health
metrics that relate to longevity
that come from getting quality
sleep and especially from
getting sufficient amounts
of quality exercise.
So that means both a combination
of cardiovascular exercise,
a minimum of 180 to 220 minutes
of so-called zone 2 cardio
per week.
So that's cardio that
you can carry out
while still maintaining
a conversation
but should you increase
the intensity any more,
you would have a hard time
completing your sentences.
But in addition to that also
doing some VO2 max work,
so getting your heart rate way,
way up at least once per week,
and also, of course, doing
resistance training either
with weights, machines
or bodyweight,
doing that at
sufficient intensity,
six sets minimum per
body part per week
to maintain not just
muscular size and strength
but equally important,
perhaps even more important,
maintaining nerve to
muscle connectivity,
which correlates with
cognitive function
and a number of other
important longevity metrics.
So again exercise, sleep,
quality nutrition, quality
social connection,
which means eliminating
as best you can toxic
social connection
and increasing quality social
connection, people that you
like and enjoy spending time
with and feel enriched by,
stress modulation, all of
these things are so key.
And of course, getting morning
sunlight, all of those things
combine to have a huge out-sized
effect compared to anything
that you could take in
pill, capsule or infusion.
So before even considering
taking any supplement or drug
to increase your longevity or
even for increasing vitality
for that matter, get those
basics of sleep, sunlight,
nutrition, movement, stress
modulation, or stress control,
I should say, and
relationships down.
Get those right.
And get that morning sunlight
to set your circadian rhythm,
because of course,
your circadian rhythm
is what anchors it all.
And I'd be completely
remiss if I didn't emphasize
yet again that any time you're
thinking of adding a supplement
or removing a supplement
from your regimen
or adding a prescription drug
or removing a prescription drug,
you absolutely
should consult you're
board-certified physician.
Thank you for joining
for the beginning
of this Ask Me Anything episode.
To hear the full episode and to
hear future episodes of these
Ask Me Anything sessions plus
to receive transcripts of them
and transcripts of the Huberman
Lab podcast standard channel
and premium tools not
released anywhere else,
please go to
hubermanlab.com/premium.
Just to remind you why we
launched the Huberman Lab
podcast premium channel,
it's really twofold.
First of all, it's to raise
support for the standard
Huberman Lab podcast
channel, which of course,
will still be continued to be
released every Monday in full
length-- we are not going to
change the format or anything
about the standard
Huberman Lab podcast--
and to fund research, in
particular research done
on human beings, so not animal
models but on human beings,
which I think we all
agree is a species
that we are most interested in.
And we are going to
specifically fund
research that is aimed
toward developing
further protocols for mental
health, physical health,
and performance.
And those protocols
will be distributed
through all channels, not
just the premium channel,
but through all channels,
Huberman Lab podcast
and other media channels.
So the idea here is to give
you information to your burning
questions in depth and
allow you the opportunity
to support the kind
of research that
provides those kinds of
answers in the first place.
Now, an especially exciting
feature of the premium channel
is that the Tiny
Foundation has generously
offered to do a
dollar-for-dollar match
on all funds raised for research
through the premium channel.
So this is a terrific
way that they're
going to amplify whatever funds
come in through the premium
channel to further support
research for science
and science-related tools for
mental health, physical health,
and performance.
If you'd like to sign up for the
Huberman Lab premium channel,
again, there's a cost
of $10 per month,
or you can pay $100 up
front for the entire year.
That will give you
access to all the AMAs.
You can ask questions and get
answers to your questions.
And you'll, of course, get
answers to all the questions
that other people ask as well.
There will also be some premium
content such as transcripts
of the AMAs and various
transcripts and protocols
of Huberman Lab podcast
episodes not found elsewhere.
And again, you'll be
supporting research
for mental health, physical
health, and performance.
You can sign up for the
premium channel by going
to hubermanlab.com/premium.
Again, that's
hubermanlab.com/premium.
And as always, thank you for
your interest in science.
[MUSIC PLAYING]